[Music]
hello YouTube chess Louis and my friends
this is guns in here welcome to the
first episode of my new chess series
Queen trap sack lines now during this
series I'm going to show you some of the
wonderful lines where either you can
actually trap your opponent queen or
sacrifice your own Queen to get a
winning position today I'm going to show
you a very amazing tricky line in
bishops or the vienna opening where you
can actually trap your opponent queen
and even though let's say in some lies
if you open and managed to escape with
his queen
he has to give up the material which
gives white of winning gauge the opening
more to start with E 4 E 5 and here in
this game
white continue with the move Bishop to
c4 if you are a Vienna player then you
can always start with the Moon Knight to
c3 now in this position as I have
highlighted over here black has few
different good choices amongst them if
your opponent plays Knight to f6 Bishop
to c5 or the move d6 then I have covered
those moves in my dirty chess trick
series episode fifth thirteenth
fourteenth and fifteen where I have
shown some very aggressive setup and
lots of tricks which you might want to
check it out so the move which we are
going to concentrate in this video is
Knight to c6
well after that my recommendation is you
continue with the move Knight to c3 and
now in the majority of cases Black has
tried either of this two moves in this
video we are going to concentrate on the
move Bishop to c5 however if your
opponent plays Knight to f6 for a time
being
you need to check out the theory section
until I come up with the another tricky
line okay so if you carefully look at
this position you have seen that so far
black has copied all the white moves but
White's next move create the big trappy
business and that is Queen to g4 so
these queries are tracking on g7 and
although black has few choices I think
by far Queen f6 is the most frequent
choice by the black player before we
look Queen to f6 there are a few
important points I like to mention over
here is King to f8 or Bishop to f8 is
already a big time concession and if
you're opening plays moves such as g6
then he is going to severely weaken his
dark square around his skiing and the
guardian of this dark square Bishop is
roaming somewhere else so this is again
a very pleasant position for the white I
have attached a sample game in the PGN
which is available in the description
which will give you a very good idea how
why should continue from here onwards
there are two news which are absolutely
not good amongst them the first one is
Knight to f6 which happened in one
bullet game where my opponent thought
that he get the tremendous winning
attack after the move rook to g8 but the
matter of fact is after White's next
move the reverse is true the second Moon
Knight to d4 is not good either because
after Queen to g7 black doesn't have
time to capture the c2 because white is
threatening the mate on f7 so the only
good reply over here is Queen to f6 but
after that Queen captures Knight
captures and the move Bishop to d3 what
is a healthy point up with a very good
position so considering all this let's
consider the obvious move at this point
that is Queen to f6
so black not only defending the g7 but
it also doing a counter attacking on f2
and what can be the more natural than
that
well except one thing that black has
straight away falling into the white
trappy camp and demonstrations start
with the move Knight to d5
so this Knight is attacking on the Queen
and also eyeing at the c7 square and
Queen cannot return back to the d8
because blacks g7 point hangs so the
first line goes as follows black is
going to capture f2 pawn which time
being saving all the thread but in fact
after this black is completely losing
the astonishing part about this opening
trap is all the moves of the black looks
so natural and still black get losing
position on the fifth move of the game
well I have done some research on this
line and what I found out that in the
Omega database 2017 so far this position
has occurred 173 times including some
title players has fallen into this line
so chances of occurring in your game is
very very high well White has the only
move King to d1 but after that now it
shows that what kind of danger black has
fallen into as white is attacking to
square that is g7 and c7 and black
cannot defend both of them the only good
way to come out of this is to play King
to f8 but this is exactly white once s
after few moves first Knight to h3
attacking the Queen and the Queen has
the only square to go that is d4 and
after Queen to d4 and the moon d3
whities all set to trap this baby with
the moon c3 and no matter however black
respond he kept this losing position now
as I have highlighted over here black
has tried this for good options and
let's look each byte on now the first
one I want to look at is d6 where
exactly black queen is going to try
because here white is going to continue
with the move Queen to g3 and blacks
idea is to capture this night and now if
I take this bishop either way
then black queen can escape while the f2
square but White has a more smarter
choice that is rook to a fun and now
indeed that Queen is going to trap for
example Bishop to b6 c3 Queen to c5 and
now b4 completely trap this black baby
well engine suggests that blacks should
capture the bishop and give up the Queen
but we should see what happens if your
opponent try to save his Queen with the
move Knight captures before but here I
should take this night and after Queen
to d4 likes idea is to counter-attack
white which is never going to happen as
after Queen captures s3 Queen captures
even yes indeed black Queen escaped but
white is going to checkmate black king
before I move on I like you to pause
this video and find out a mating
sequence for the white well I hope you
find this wonderful blow bam ha-ha-ha
well that response is force black has to
take this rook and after that night kept
his b6 a discover Jack King to a fade
and now Queen to e6 and white is
threatening to V checkmate which cannot
be prevented
okay let's consider the second move that
is h-file so black is counter-attacking
of a queen no problem white is going to
play Queen to f3 and now blacks idea is
to play the move d6 well at first sight
this looks so cool
but after white's sneaky reply that is
skiing too even not only white has
diffused all the black threads but
renewing the threat of the moon c3 now
to highlight the danger in the blacks
position I like to show you one of my
game with a very higher ranked opponent
where he continued with the move Bishop
to g4 I responded with the move Queen to
f4 and now black has to do something to
escape his queen in the game he decided
to capture my night but after G captures
s3 Knight to f6
I simply play the move c3 my opponent
find nothing better than Queen to f2 and
after Queen captures Bishop captures and
King captures after the whole sequence
yes indeed Black has save his queen but
for the cost of a piece the 3rd mu I
want to consider is Knight to f6 which
has again the same idea to
counter-attack of a queen well here why
should continue with the move Knight
captures now if Queen goes back to d6
then white is going to be piece up so
the critical line is G captures f6 and
after that white has this wonderful move
Queen to h5 so threatening a checkmate
only way to defend this is to play
Knight to d8
if you open and place the MU D Phi then
this is the last time he is going to
play it because after c3 black queen is
a goner
so Knight to d8 at this position is a
force move after that white get a
winning attack with the MU rook to f1
kindly note if Queen goes to the d6
then Bishop to g5 is a very strong reply
so in one online game black continue
with the move Bishop to e7
but what he
over Lucas White's next death Ling reply
the ball is in your court guys kindly
pause the video and find out White's
best reply in this position did you find
it
let's see the dazzling movers Bishop to
f7 well Black has to take this otherwise
Bishop 2x6 leads to the checkmate so in
the game black plays Knight captures f7
but then comes Knight to g5 threatening
of maid
so again black responds his force black
has to take this another piece but after
Bishop captures g5
black is completely hopeless he tried
Queen to d6 but then comes this forcing
maid sequence that is Bishop to at 6
King to g8 and now rook to f3 and there
is an unavoidable checkmate last but not
least what happens if you open and plays
Bishop to b6 so idea is to giving the
Queen escape route no problem here what
should continue with the move Queen to
h4 so white is now threatening the move
Knight captures b6 and then
checkmate on the f7 and if black clay
here g6 then Queen to f3 is a very
strong reply I got this position in
online blitz game against a 2100 rated
player where he decided to continue with
the Moon Knight to d8 so saving all the
tactics on f7 I responded with the move
rook to have fun so renewing the thread
so my opponent again diffused the thread
with the mu abscess
black is hanging on but after White's
next amazing reply Knight to g5 black
position is completely crumbling
in the game he played c6 but this gives
white too much initiative I start by
hitting his queen with the moon c3 Queen
to c5 now another tempo move Bishop to
e3 Queen to d6 and now the deciding blow
Knight captures b6 a captures v6 and
night to f7
black cannot take this night because of
the checkmate and the counter-attacking
move g6 doesn't work over here because
then white can execute a winning
sequence so before I show it to you I
want you to pause this video and find it
by your own
are you ready let's go for it
so sequence start with the move Bishop
check King to e7 Knight captures d6 pawn
captures Knight captures see a check
rook captures and now the sting in the
tail fish up to g7 and white wins apiece
in a broad daylight well I hope you
enjoy and learn this wonderful Queen
treppie line in bishops and the vnr play
well thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
on my video and I'll meet you in my next
episode very soon bye and take care